former President Bill Clinton appeared
at a campaign event for a Josh Reilly a
Democrat running for the New York house
and it's less this showing you this clip
is less about Josh Riley it's more about
Bill Clinton perfectly summing up modern
era Republicans I'll just play the clip
and then we'll talk about it the
Republicans are pretty simple
to lay there
very miserable
and I want you to be very angry
and I vote I want you to vote for us
and we'll make it worse but we'll blame
them yeah
[Applause]
that is exactly what the modern
Republican party is they don't propose
policy they don't bring any big ideas of
any value or substance let's think
through an example think about the
economy right now Republicans are saying
the economy is bad right now the economy
is bad right now that's not true the
economy is actually pretty solid right
now by all standard economic indicators
is inflation High yes but we're at
almost full employment GDP growth is
back stock market is
shaky but not a disaster we have all the
data so they lie by saying the economy
is currently bad
they say Democrats are terrible for the
economy and we'll make it better vote
for us
the truth is historically Democrats are
better for the economy historically we
have higher job growth when there's a
Democratic president stock market
performs better under a Democratic
president we have lower unemployment
under a Democratic president GDP growth
is higher under a Democratic president
inflation is lower under a Democratic
president on average okay
so then you elect them they don't make
it any better because they're worse for
the economy we know that
but when it gets worse they'll say well
it's the fault of Democrats if they
control the Senate and the White House
and the economy doesn't do as well as
they claim it should have done they will
say well even though we had the White
House and the Senate the economy didn't
do so well because Democrats controlled
the house it is spot on spot on analysis
from Bill Clinton here and they've
abandoned policy as I've told you many
times before and it's these cultural
issues these contrived issues of
wokeness and litter boxes and in fact
that's exactly what I want to talk about
next before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description